hey guys it's pete peppers here with a
level 2 97 walkthrough with tips for
candy crush soda saga a lot of people
have trouble at this level and it's
frustrating and it takes some tries
sometimes you have to get a pretty good
bored but I'm going to talk to you about
some of the things that I did in the
basic strategy hopefully we can get
through it so the general idea in the
beginning is to get this Jam to spread
out some and we're going to do that is
best we can we just can't without a lot
of room in the very beginning it's hard
to find a lot of different choices so
we're going to take what the board gives
us but at the same time just be looking
for spots or we can set up some specials
and we want to get rid of the blockers
but we also want to bring out that Jam
so like here you know you can see I drop
this down so I can shoot straight
through the blockers and I'm I'm
clearing out the blockers as I go I got
the jam a little bit out I like the idea
of trying to get some below if possible
to but you can see it's sort of a mess
down there there's no matches I can make
that I'll spread it so we have a color
bomb I would like to match it with this
fish but there's no way to do that
matching it with that striped would be
cool too but I can't do that either so
I'm just going to go ahead and probably
use it and on a jam board a color bomb
by itself can be pretty helpful because
i can pick like this orange and it'll
turn all the orange squares all the
squares at have orange i'm going to put
jam there so you can see that that's not
bad you know i would preferably like to
use it in a combo as often as I can so
like here is where this is where things
change a little bit all right so all
right so I'm going to hold it here for a
second so what we want to do is we want
to make a big combo right we only have
six moves left we have jam to go all
over the place and we still have quite a
bit of blockers so you know there's no
way we're going to just be able to like
chip away at these and get them so at
the top here you can see we have two
setups for four color bombs we have a
yellow and a red we got the tool on the
side with the gap so I'm going to make
this match down here it gets you already
started to you and if you don't have
something like that you know the next
best thing color bomb combos would be
good and then strike + wrap would be
really good like if we had like so if we
can set up a strike post wrap up here we
can take out most of the blockers and
spread Jam pretty far at the same time
so I'm going to go ahead and like I said
match the red at the bottom because that
gives me a chance to make a color ball
and then I actually get a little bit
better of a return I get to color bombs
so that's a no brainer we're going to
match those together and that's going to
get rid of most of the blockers and all
spread jam all the way across and so now
we can you know just make matches to
finish this off so the so the main thing
here is that like I said you can't it's
it's one of those frustrating boards
there's not a lot of room don't have a
lot of a lot of space so you know in the
beginning try to spread that jam
whenever you can look for combos as soon
as things open up a bit and just really
take your time towards the end because
once the board gets a little bit wider
you're going to have to make a couple
big combos in order to finish so i hope
this helped you out hang in there it
took me a few tries even though i had
beat it before it took quite a few tries
so you know just hang in there keep that
stuff in mind and you'll get it sooner
or later please like this video and
subscribe to my channel I'll be putting
out more of these videos with tips built
in and I have lots of other videos for
all the you know as soon as levels come
out I get them out so make sure you
subscribe so you can come back and visit
and see my stuff again alright thanks